[Music]
now remember if you subscribe to the
spectators youtube channel for free
you'll
never miss another episode just click
the subscribe button at the bottom right
of the screen now finally this year the
office of prime minister of british
prime minister
marks its 300th anniversary yeah
1721 walpole
should there be a museum dedicated to
downing street
and its occupants to mark the occasion
historian and biographer of numerous
prime ministers anthony seldon
he argues in this week's edition of the
spectator
there should be and he joins us now
anthony welcome to
spectator tv up why do you think you
know
you bring up the point that every
president now uh in the america has
their own library
and a bespoke building and scholars can
go and study all the papers and so on
why have we never done anything like
that for british prime ministers
well andrew the prime minister of course
is not head of state
um unlike the 45 u.s
president so there's an extra dimension
there but effectively
um the prime minister has taken over
many of the responsibilities
of the head of state so when robert
warpole
back in april 1721 was invited to be
first lord of the treasury
and chancellor of the exchequer the
office was combined at the time
um he was in awe
of george the first george ii
from 1727 and they were powerful people
so i think it's something about
um the fact that you know america
there's more money but there's also
head of state and i think we need to
have more reverence
and um recognition of the importance of
this office on this anniversary
if it's not done now andrew when will it
be done i thought
your article in this week's spectator i
thought was fascinating is you reminded
us
of the incredibly important decisions
not just for britain but for the whole
world
that were taken in that cabinet room in
10 downing street with prime ministers
cheering them
decisions that in the end lost as the 13
colonies and led to the
declaration of independence decisions to
go to war
against germany in 1914
1939 huge global
decisions and yet we we have
no museum that that deals with this
it is a remarkable gap is it not
it is i mean it is uh the
most famous address in the world
um the us was
governed from downing street for its
first 55 years
until the declaration of independence
uh and so it's very important to the
americans but it's important to
india it's important to china it's um
that this from this office and
not least in the 19th century when
britain
was arguably the most important power
in the globe um the decisions were
pumped out of that
uh office and and so
it's not just a british asset it it's a
global treasure
uh and what's so funny is that you know
it's still being used as
an office and people who work in there
uh
are really pretty unaware of
of the history of it which is exactly
why
i thought this would be a good idea well
i've been down the street quite a few
times
but it was your article that brought
home to me
the history over that i hadn't really
thought enough about
if we had a museum of prime ministers or
whatever we call it anthony
what would be in it how do you envisage
this museum
well i think we have to ask who would it
be
for uh and i we have to accept the fact
that
unlike the white house where and many
other uh offices of heads of state and
heads of government
across the world where visitors can come
in so there is
a a public education role in that you
can't do it in downing street
because it's too small too awkward i
mean it's
wildly improbable this terrorist house
uh in a pretty unpre-possessing street
um has become uh this great office it
wasn't purpose-built
uh like um um the elysee like um
the viceroy's palace and there's a white
house yeah
[Laughter]
can you imagine wellington uh you know
if he's got his house
on hyde park one hyde park yeah
absolutely i mean you know i mean
why would you want to go and live in
this
very smelly dirty sinking
grubby house so some of them did i mean
pit did
uh and um peeled it and
walpole uh did but a lot of the grandes
who tended to be
prime minister so i think what you'd do
is you would have a
replica of the most important rooms in
that building and not just
i think it's also important that it's
regionally spread also
uh so that you know there is one up in
edinburgh there is one
uh in cardiff and in belfast too so
there's a sense of it being the office
of
um of the whole of the united kingdom
rather than
the prime minister for the south east of
england which is often
uh not least by dint of the derivation
of the prime minister's
what it seemed to be so let's finish on
this and uh you know let's hope your
idea takes off
spectators can help on that we'd be
delighted uh to
to do so uh helping raise some money and
and so on but so 300 years of british
prime ministers going back to walpole
in 1721. let me ask you about the best
or the worst in
two sections let's take since 1945
modern times if we can call it that uh
over the past uh
70 odd years um
who've been the best prime ministers two
contenders
andrew both wildly different the second
one largely undid the work of the first
and they're clement actly from 1945 to
51 the labour prime minister
who achieved what lloyd george didn't
after the first world war in 1918
of building a land fit for heroes
introducing
the social and economic policies that
set the tone for the next 30 years
and positioned britain's place in the
world in the u.n
found a member of nato atomic um
power atomic power in the world and
independence for india and much more so
really
a defining administration the second one
obviously margaret thatcher
from 1979 to 1990 not just
um because she was the first woman and
she won three
general elections first time since
liverpool at the beginning of the 19th
century but she remolded the whole
uh shape of of britain um and i'm
picking much of what
atlee had done so i mean
on the world stage uh a giant figure the
most
uh significant prime minister globally
since 1945
by a distance so they're the two giants
i agree with that i think that ackley
and thatcher are the two
most significant uh prime ministers
since 1945 because we're exactly for the
reasons you
gave okay let me go to before 39. now
you've
noticed i've missed out to 40 to 45.
uh with your agreement i hope i'm i'm
parking churchill
as being suey generous uh
in roy jenkins biography biography of
him he does he despite
being a huge admirer of gladstone he
says he was the greatest
prime minister let me park church
churchill
before 1939 who would you mark out
as our greatest prime ministers well i
think warpol
because he created the office still the
longest serving
prime minister andrew 21 years and he so
nearly got flipped out at different
points it was
pretty tenuous often his survival not
least when
george the first his great patron died
then you go to pitt the younger who
really consolidated the office
without pip being there for most of the
time between
1783 and 1806 during the
revolutionary napoleonic wars holding
the country together
and he took on foreign policy as i
understand it which previously
had really been the palace around
foreign policy absolutely i mean
resting it out of the control of um
george iii he was a much more activist
um
uh king than his george one and two
and but you know he got his fingers so
badly burnt on foreign policy
with the american civil war and the loss
of the 13
colonies that he lost his confidence
and pitt uh was supremely uh confident
in directing that war but consolidating
the post and then i think very briefly
you have to go to gladstone uh because
he uh
shaped the premiership for the era of
mass political parties
and the the beginning of the mass
franchise beginning programmatic
politics the idea that you put a program
to
the public in the general election i
think you have to finish off
then with lloyd george um absolute
scandal
arguably the biggest scandal there are
lots of contenders since warpole
perhaps ever but he did see the country
successfully through the last
two years of the first world war and
dynamic
at the treaty of versailles uh getting
britain's position
banging there in the post-war settlement
and solving the irish question uh
you know the question is why there's so
few great prime ministers
compared to say german chancellors since
1945
or indeed u.s presidents many of them
have disappointed
indeed there's good choices there i
think anthony you've got a book coming
out on british prime ministers happened
to you
in um beginning of april with cambridge
where i tried to bring together i wrote
it during covic but really
for 40 years i've been writing about
prime ministers so it was nice to be
able to
pull all that together and think you
know why has the office survived
is it still the same office who opens up
your question
you know who are the great ones and why
and why are there not more
but also how can we improve the office
for the fourth decade for the fourth
century and the title of your book
uh impossible office for the question
mark impossible
has it just become impossible to succeed
anthony selden thank you for your time
today on spectator tv it's great to talk
to you
[Music]
you